Fox and Marvel they always do great work
together ever since I was three I wanted
to play quarterback for the New York
Giants aspiring to mediocrity the prop
master put an apple on this teacher's
desk because this villain had no prop
master and someone just went with the
cliches also to make the teacher look
like even more of a read hating asshole
I call it a biomatter shuttle aka
transporters from Star Trek also
Fantastic Four reboot waste time with
kid Reed Richards a backstory that
precisely tells us he's been thinking
about the biomatter shuttle since he was
a kid it's a jump back in time so
wasteful I wonder why they didn't start
with a recreation of the Big Bang why
high tests on biological materials well
he spends a lot of time on young Reed
trying to convince me that a
ten-year-old could ever be this smart
yet still be in public school so the
future thing got this catchphrase from
his abusive asshole brother
I wonder what Jack Kirby might have to
say about this representation I'm just
looking for a power converter Reed is an
uber genius child but his morals are as
he tries to steal the power converter
before the five-minute mark also why
didn't he just go to the tashi station I
realize Reed's family is poor but this
is supposedly 2007 according to the
movie the year the iPhone came out and
two years after YouTube debuted but he's
still using a 1996 computer for some
reason and it still works well enough to
power his bull matter transporter how
much further back can you really go at
this point though if there's anything I
know about New York Jets fans who wear
Jets caps and have Jets pennants on
their walls it's that they absolutely
love college football contest between
UConn and Virginia also isn't this a
school night didn't we see young Reed
Richards at school followed by Ben later
that night working at the junkyard this
verity game was played on October 13th a
Saturday and maybe the movie jumped
ahead to Saturday without telling us but
this mean
the rocks don't run from the same place
to car one - where is that I don't know
yet
okay first of all how do you do this
experiment without any idea where the
car might go
are you Tesla from the prestige because
that was set a hundred years prior to
this and you're smarter than God second
of all how do you know the car didn't
turn into those rocks through some
scientific transmogrifier accident third
of all this movie is starting off
telling me a young child built a Star
Trek transporter on his own but has no
idea where its ends I haven't even seen
the main cast yet and this movie is
testing my patience movie finally begins
after a seven-minute preview for the
movie explorers also this movie might
have been badass if it had literally
jumped ahead in time seven years every
seven minutes of the film alas this is
the only time it does that have you ever
seen a science fair with so many
participants using the exact same trifle
display also this entire first row of
science projects here looks completely
devoid of student
almost as though they were thin on
extras for the day or something shall I
alert the fire department why does High
School Reid have any continued
interaction with his fifth grade teacher
I mean my associate Ben have been
working on it every day since fifth
grade when we launched the beta version
in my garage you could have started the
movie here Mulk
the model car please Ben give me a
fucking break I mean these two assholes
were obsessed with the science project
forgot to bring a model car to the
presentation stealing model airplanes
from children absolutely no one is
startled when this backboard shatters
almost like they were expecting it or
perhaps even from this we're not science
project that clearly works and is
amazing is disqualified because reads
fifth grade teacher is a dick I don't
see any real science here and yet you've
been teaching it for years you say us
cameras capture child actor casually
talking to miles Stifler we've gone so
far as to send matter to another
dimension but we haven't been able to
maintain to feel long enough to bring
that matter back what is the government
scientists doing at a science fair
they're really hoping to find that one
kid who mastered interdimensional travel
so they can finish their own work also
government corporate secret science dude
spills all the beans to this high school
kid he just met him for all he knows has
a blabbermouth I think you've cracked
interdimensional travel sweet you're one
of the judges right also somewhere
someone thought you know what the best
way to reboot the Fantastic Four would
be science fair we found the same thing
you did how do you know what he all
forget it I'm clocking out at the
goddamn 10-minute mark movie sets new
record for pissing me off in the
shortest amount of time also is this the
first time Reid has succeeded surely he
had some measure of success before
coming to the science fair with this
project so why didn't these obviously
Big Brother government corporate peeps
come spook him into joining them well
before the science fair like after his
first successful trial in the garage for
instance they are literally scoping out
random high school science fairs for new
talent are they there specifically here
for him right here's yet another comic
book skyscraper I'm supposed to slobber
over when honestly I'm just kind of sky
street for it out guys Shanaya
Reid Reid doesn't give his full name or
even his last name first and instead
assumes his first name is all these guys
need which is stupid Richard yes of
course we've been expecting you but
we'll be then redeems read by having
this asshole actually know who you is by
first name only I guess they wanted to
pump the Laura Reed Richards a bit by
having him be heard of but the scene
plays out clumsy as a moose on skates
these guys just got to this room
yep there are pictures hung up all over
the wall and a fucking bedspread on the
bed I think in the wrong room wait Ben
didn't get to come here - this is a room
age and only Reid is getting a
scholarship will be fuck's been right in
the ear
why did Reid stack 20,000 League
the sea with all these chemistry books
Victor Von Doom is on here he started
this project despite the fact that
Victor shown instability in the past and
the fact that Reed is the missing piece
they need and the fact that his name is
Victor Von Doom dr. storm thinks they
need him on this project
let's see classical music a series of
security cams a nearly totally dark room
and of course playing violent video
games yep he's a villain so I know that
Reed's idea needs some work a little
smoothing out but don't they have all
the information they need no but this
one who's gonna make it out like they
need months to make this machine work
rudimentary Elementary I would have
removed a hundred sins if we found out
Von Doom was reading a thesaurus
Elementary is basically a child's
drawing of a thing he got to work that
you couldn't get to work God why do
movies feel the need to write characters
this way you're not the Savior here
you're the guy who got close but
couldn't seal the deal but now there's a
guy who did and we think maybe your
previous experiments might shed some
light that's it people running the earth
the same ones running it into the ground
so maybe it deserves what it's got
coming to it after doom over here did
you guys feel good I think we were
actually punched in the nose with
obvious Ness I'm actually bleeding also
villain hates human beings because we're
all awful assholes cliche so he got
Norman Wilson and Wallace from The Wire
playing father and son in this movie and
it just makes me wish I was watching The
Wire in fact I think I will watch The
Wire Fantastic Four is more The Fast and
the fan for stick hero at the beginning
of the movie who enters the street race
suddenly has car trouble cliche how much
do I love this street race let me count
the ways
what are you racing again what is this
big hero 6 The Fast and the Furious The
Phantom Menace meaningless montage full
of people building things we had no clue
what they are writing stupid on a
dry-erase are bored and looking into
microscopes the speedy construction of
this thing would be really impressive if
it didn't look Vegas but everyone knows
when you put together a team of young
geniuses you need more than one hot girl
otherwise someone's gonna get jealous
and turn evil after she falls in love
with one of the other dudes we're
finished I mean this was after a day
right here is it I get the thing back to
earth
oh okay we're done at least that's how I
imagined it maybe this really did take
months also if they were really finished
how is it that no one told Victor about
it until now obvious leftover to rise at
the Planet of the Apes effects were
copied and pasted into this movie what
you are in effect seeing is someone
clicking ctrl-c and ctrl-v
Jesus you can't try with a rat first or
affirm this is an organic test not a
primate test what you sent a monkey to
another dimension and somehow expect
video to travel how for millions of
light years back to you in real-time you
do know that even light takes a long
time to travel at space right here's
where I wish the movie had taken a weird
turn and made the monkey get whatever
superpowers these asshole humans get
when they go but no one would find out
until after the humans had gone and they
come back to find super monkey
terrorizing the earth and they have to
fight it
that would have played man it's like
we're next after one successful test you
bet you I think it's time to start
coordinating with our friends at NASA
the evil corporate guy decides they need
to send astronauts instead of the people
who built it this sounds like some
horrible short-sighted decision but he's
absolutely right you guys know who build
the Apollo spacecraft when to the moon
so dooms going to make this speech about
other people who built the Apollo
spacecraft didn't get any glory but the
people who built the Apollo spacecraft
also didn't have test pilot expertise
like Neil Armstrong I mean why are you
qualified to shoot yourselves into space
anyway people who make baseballs aren't
Mike Trout either unless we go first
scientists decide to personally run the
machine at their own peril cliche also
let's think about this for a minute they
do this because they want the glory but
do you think this company they work for
is even going to acknowledge it hell no
they'll be fired maybe even go to jail
and they'll still get NASA to run the
Machine and you can't tell me these
smart people decided to do this because
they got a little drunk
even worse our so-called heroes people
of science decide to drag totally out of
his element Ben Grimm into this launch
just like every comic book movie the
heroes just happen to have a perfectly
sized suit for the guy they called in to
join them just an hour ago
we didn't call her - for real Ben gets
to go before her these guys are assholes
she worked just as hard as they did
maybe they thought you'd be against it
but that's exactly why you guys need to
ask her anyway want some how sue didn't
get any other warnings about the machine
until the quantum gate was active these
doors open automatically to let them out
in the new dimension even though they
did no such thing for the monkey on the
trial run monkey didn't even get a space
helmet hey Victor I think you should see
this you better come take a look at this
cliche also putting the American flag in
the ground causes bright green cracks to
emanate from the surface and none of
these guys thinks maybe we should head
back
nope uh-uh I'm good the guy who loves to
street race is the one asshole with a
fear of heights when did all these nerds
get rock climbing skills this is so much
nope going on right now that I wonder if
these guys can even be considered
geniuses anymore
movie steals the friends go to someplace
dangerous and touch something that will
give them super powers thing from
Chronicle these guys are scientists
right why would any of them think that
they should approach this definitely
alien energy pond are you fucking
serious you did just see him green milk
right even with all the stuff going on I
don't know where this fire came from
it's been nothing but green goo
explosion since this all started I also
don't know how fire decides to wrap
around Johnny and turn him into a
superhero instead of pure ash but hey
that's the kind of movie were watching
right oh my god exactly been turned into
a stone man because rocks went into his
capsule
Johnny turned into a fiery guy because
fire got in his capsule but apparently
Reed Richards turned into a stretch guy
because I can't figure it out really
think believe for the plot enough alien
world essence spilled out into the room
upon their return to also in picsou with
superpowers
oh yeah and she's invisible because oh I
guess
I cut the black the Editors best friend
damn this movie cuts the black a lot
we're analyzing what happened to you
whatever it is we can find a way to
reverse it uncapable implied promises
also almost an hour into this one hour
39 minute movie and we are still just
wrapping up the origin other powers both
bends reveal as the thing is watered
down heavily by the fact that we saw his
ass in a fairly Willet room just a
minute ago nothing of note happened
until a year later another dimension
that our scientists have taken to
calling planet zero
no they haven't surely would have called
this the Bexar FF for dirty sex pleasure
boob before going to plant at zero we
have the direct link awesome
I know bureaucracy takes a while but
you're just now asking for permission to
send more people back to the superpower
planet are you saying it took that long
to rebuild the machine because the movie
spares us on how these characters began
to cope with their abilities in favor of
going straight to the fact that they're
working for the government no questions
asked but in a reboot where you bother
to go all the way back to Reed's
childhood to tell this story well I
leave that out if that's the type of
thing you'd cut out why not just start
this movie right at the point where Reed
gets accepted to Baxter and have them
beat a Fantastic Four within 15 minutes
your boss why are you on fire right now
D prefer being on fire while having
conversations either these government
people are forcing Ben to watch his in
the field work on video the more he
chooses to by the way a scene from us I
can't finish it without Reed Reed's not
coming back he abandoned us left us here
yeah how exactly did he just leave the
facility without anyone seeing it the
last time we saw him he was here but we
don't know how he escaped or even how a
urinates without his penis grouping into
the water the FBI CIA and NSA have blips
of reed here and there but they can't
seem to see you pattern what the hell do
you mean you mean Reeves learned how to
be a stealth super spy since he left the
building is he looking for anything else
he was searching for him you know him I
seen the guy you should instinctively
know his Ben Grimm is he looking for
anything else he was searching for him
turn on the music to find reach patterns
she's gonna find read by listening to
music too many seconds of her glancing
at 15 monitors and figuring out where
Reed is oh come on like none of the top
minds in the military at the
super-secret facility searching for Reed
could have found this frickin pattern on
their own Reber flexibly looks back for
anyone on this deserted road with
reverse projection x-ray vision who
could possibly see him subtly change his
face in the car also it would have been
interesting to actually see him learning
this skill but Livvy forces it down your
throat with 30 minutes left Reed borrows
heavily from the hole but that's a
different studio so who the fuck cares
he was born March 14th 1986 the movie
started in 2007 with Ben and 5th grade
remember but some serious physical and
mental stunting for a 21 year old it's
definitely Jamie Bell's birthday but not
the fucking characters that's him isn't
it great that he loved that book so much
he made a huge point to tell you about
it and why is such an obvious name
anyway this probably should have killed
before gotta read some how Ben despite
his deformity is still convinced to turn
on his lifelong friend by the military
that is obviously just using it movie
rips on star trek into darkness it's
about this time in the movie that I'm
wondering shouldn't Tim Blake Nelson be
playing the leader by now I saw him get
infused with the gamma radiation in the
Incredible Hulk so Johnny you need to
listen and I did listen to you and
that's what got me here in the first
place wait did dr. Franklin tell
everybody to get drunk and then use a
machine that have been tested one time
just so they could all get some
artificial glory I miss that scene how
did Victor gate a Jedi costume while on
the other planet possible oh shut the
fuck up with your not possible how many
tens of thousands of dollars did you use
to film somebody saying not possible in
a science fiction movie that's our job
assholes possible it really doesn't seem
like it should be possible I agree I
want to talk to him nobody talks to him
until I do and find the others to their
quarters you mean confine the other
superpower others to their quarters I
mean if they don't wanna how knowing
what the other dimension did to read and
company after a few minutes sure seat
belts will definitely hold this guy in
place we have 14 minutes left in the
movie and we're just now being
introduced to Doctor Doom if this
world's must die so their mind may live
so be it why did you even bother coming
back with the crew if you loved it so
much on your world were you faking
injury to get back to earth just so you
could then go back to this planet and do
what you could have done before they
took you back and that's another thing
why does the machine necessarily have to
go to this planet every time anyway what
specific coordinates is it set for I
guess the two planets are connected in
space-time but you I don't like it Darth
Vader called he'd like to know how
you're more powerful than he is and yet
still take down a bull by the Fantastic
Four imagine if this was the first act
this would be on the verge of being a
cool movie instead I get the sneaking
suspicion this whole movie is a first
act just in case it was popular enough
to get a sequel first off was Johnny
thinking he doesn't even know where Doom
is or what he's capable of this guy was
sequestered in his room and everything
happened second off how did sue react so
quickly
out of my way Franklin I'm going home
this is your home son what just let him
go back and this is all over for reals
and you don't just let it happen only
the power to create a new world more CGI
budget is saved with the decision to
have Victor's lips not move after his
transformation brilliant
Victor once again mine powers an enemy
across the room but will still somehow
be defeated in this movie promise I see
dr. Franklin got that dr. doom attack
but lets you save final words before
dying Reed Richards is also known as
Niles narrator in some Marvel
adaptations or just plain literal miles
teller oh good the final fight is gonna
take place at a faraway dimension we
know nothing about awesome
should make for some interesting physics
I guess thanks Reed no wet again Victor
seems utterly omnipotent also you stole
that from The Incredibles for the final
fight instead of just green mine
blasting Reed into space
Victor decides to throw rocks at him and
then fistfight him because this ends in
13 minutes including credits and only
Victor seems to care about getting us to
the finale even if it means his own
stupid-ass demise we can't beat him he's
stronger than any of us yes but he's not
stronger than all of us he clearly is
you guys in tandem took a huge ass
beating a minute ago instead of flying
victor takes the slow ass rock elevator
as though he's unaware this movie only
has 12 minutes left a total runtime
also rock elevator also you stole that
from scar on the Lion King and you
didn't even sing a song to earn it guy
it was mind owning everyone just a few
minutes ago somehow has to resort to
throwing rocks at his opponents on his
home planet despite the fact that he
turns invisible gives away his position
and is at least 10 to 20 feet away from
doom doom stands there and takes this
punch no seriously what just happen is
the movie gonna even try to explain
these four somehow fly back to earth via
the direct to other dimension link doom
hell roll the credits already is beyond
unsee palpable already just shut it down
thank God black hole's take forever to
produce even though untold energy was
hitting the planet a minute ago while
the world may not know what she did to
save it the men and women in this room
do that's why we prepared our usual box
of croissants cinnamon rolls and
enchiladas is that a tree full of shaped
turkey and what if we say no say yes
military agrees to the Fantastic Four
demands because the thing is scary I
think that the four of us should have a
name you know for marketing purposes
having nothing to do with the work we
came here to do how about two guys a
girl and the thing that nobody wanted
artificial rivalry between Johnny and
Ben is artificial yes it's fantastic say
that again what an asshole like you meet
it set again as if you misheard it or
need it repeated for dramatic reveal or
some is fantastic yes it is guys I got
it
ready yeah Wow built this movie and
Ultron ended on a not completing the
line moment can't call either one a
ripoff of the other they both came out
the same summer but still misses some
bolt right pretty sure it is also roll I
guess they're rolling credits okay my
bad shut it down
the sum of the square roots of any two
sides of an isosceles triangle is equal
to the square root of the remaining side
I think you've cracked interdimensional
trap space a final frontier
it's real
Hey
it's the only chance we have to figure
out what happened to us and reverse it
I'm gonna dull Victor don't do this
there is no future there is no Dana
there is only you